إعلان جديد يطرح السؤال ،
تعتذر امرأتان أكثر من الرجال آسف الله يسأل
سؤالًا غبيًا آسف أعطني دقيقة
آسف لأننا أردنا معرفة ما إذا كان هذا صحيحًا
أو إذا كان مجرد صورة نمطية آسف آسف
آسف هل تعتذر النساء أكثر من الرجال
نعم نعم حسنًا  لا أعتقد
أن الرجل يقول آسف أكثر من النساء
بالتأكيد نعم لا أعتقد أن الأمر
يتعلق بالضرورة بالجنس ، أشعر أن
النساء يقولون بشكل عشوائي إنني آسف حتى
عندما لا يوجد شيء للاعتذار
عما تقوله آسف  أنا آسف لأنني
لم أجب على هاتفي ، أنا آسف لأنني
لم أقرأ لك نصًا إذا صادفت
أشخاصًا أفعل ذلك لمدة 15 مرة في اليوم
، وأقول آسف ، لقد قابلت شخصًا في
وقت سابق وقلت آسف  مثل شخص ما
اصطدم بي ، سأقول أوه ، أنا آسف لأنني
نسيت الكثير من الأشياء ، لذلك يجب أن
أقول لزوجتي ، أنا آسف ، لقد نسيت الوقت إذا
قال أحدهم آسف كثيرًا ، أعتقد
أنهم يجعلونهم  نوع ضعيف قليلاً من
العروض ربما تدني احترام الذات أو مفرط
الحساسية لا أعتقد أنه
يشير إلى ضعف نعم  h أعتقد أنه شخص
يتمتع بالأخلاق الحميدة والقيم الحميدة